hey hello hi I just colleague again she
is pissed drunk you
need
now each way as she into that
car defitely all
right
hi I'm
F just hold on a second man
right well
um you been drinking tonight um I
had
wine uh somebody just said stated that
you may be may be drinking you swerving
I'm fine
you you light
din I'm fine
honestly got fight with my
boyfriend I just want to go home well
what's going on what happened to your
boyfriend we're we we're supposed to be
engaged and she's been cheating on me
with his first
girlfriend from like 5 years
ago honestly
like right now I'm trying to like my
cousin lives
on and I would I'll keep my car here and
I'll just go
to okay just hold on one
second just literally the worst day in
my
life
mc14 go
ahead anybody us certified feel about
it is just right down the street
again just hold on a second just hold on
a second okay your
partner me rep can I just get my purse
respawn
sit down shut
the I can you just me a do that for me
please
I Ty Park in the wrong spot so let me
explain to you I know this is
like okay let me just explain to you
what happened so we we got a phone call
that your call was blocking the driveway
but the driveway is right here yes I
know I understand that but your bumper
is overlapping the line of the
driveway okay so that's why I got I got
to comeing okay then I got
here the um the call caller notified me
that quote unquote you're pissed drunk
and then check you out do I seem piss
drunk no you don't but I have someone
I'm very upset I have I have somebody
coming that feels a body that that would
know so I have to just double check
before I let you
leave hi officer I'm just trying to
leave I I am so sorry I parked in this I
thought right here is like the garage
like I'm so sorry I'll go to right now
you can't
leave stay here for now just just hold
on a second all right we got we got
we're situated in a
second what for
what
my
mom I my family lives here as long as
you're not blocking the driveway you're
fine
right so let me just give you
I so what happened was we're here for a
block drive right and I'm inen and the
bumper is hanging over the line and then
the person I called also said she P the
car okay so we
just she was in the car she didn't with
my doctor Lea father the mayor of s
River thank you my parents are coming
but like I
said driveway C I have done nothing
wrong ma'am I just sorry that I had a
hard time maam I'm sorry to hear that I
explained to you already what why we
were here it's because your bumper was
overlapping the line of the driveway I
understand that I I understand that but
it's it's a tight turn for for the
residents
sorry so I origin got a call here for a
BL so you know it's over it's over the
line everything and I came back to fill
out the summons and then the uh the
caller called back and said that she
goes I think this person's P drunk and
you have to check her out was she in the
car she was in the car but she didn't
she didn't move the car or anything like
that she was sitting in the driver seat
though the edge was on that yeah the car
was on okay so when you when you respond
you saw her in the she was in the driver
but the car wasn't moved yet that I know
okay cuz I looked at you
know
yeah now I don't know she is drunk I
just you know from my
eyewitness M right you doing it yeah
what do
we she she was in I'll give run down
what
happen the vehicle I can take a picture
was it moving I went up to the window I
said man have you been drinking tonight
and she said she she did have a drink MH
and then um she got out the car and said
I'm going to go home I W home yeah
because my boyfriend cheated on me I'm
sorry I she didn't say it but she said
someone
lives Mom okay and you she got out of
the car what with the she had the
vehicle on when she
was
okay probably use that sidew whatever
best for you so going to perform a test
so for now
my I'm going let Know audio video I
understand but I don't understand why
because I'm not even in the garage
like
offic so I just have to do a series of
test you pass a series of tests then you
could be on your
way my father's a doctor he's going to
be coming that's perfectly fine I need
to do a series based off of the
observations that my my my my mom and
dad said I don't have to there's no
reason why I
said I mean you can deny it's up I deny
it so you're not going to conduct the
fieldi test you you understand that you
please put down on the phone you
understand that if you do if you do
declin the test we have to go up a law
observations that you didn't that you
consuming alcohol today I
dad you're trying because my car I'll
send you pictures
is blocking a little bit not even the
garage and they want to they have 1 2 3
four five cops
here yeah trying to say I don't
know what's your father can you hear Dr
Lea Dr Dr Lea sir my name is Officer Roy
from theing Police Department um the
reason being that I got re I'm certified
miliy officer the initial officer um
your daughter was in the vehicle and it
was it was on it is property Park it's
slightly in the driveway a little bit
but nothing out of this Ordinary World
but due to the initial officer she
admitted
to while the vehicle was F which is why
I'm literally vehicle was not on because
it's a
fog
does that mean that she's driving it so
when the vehicle's on it's technically
op being operated technically through
like the state law so I just have to do
a series of tests if she doesn't want to
that's perfectly fine she has her own
right to do so she doesn't have to she
doesn't want to but we're going to have
to go based off of the initial officer's
observation if I conduct the test and
she passes she gets to go on her Merry
way and we how do I know you don't just
like
like make me but I'm just explaining
everything I want my law it was it's
parked properly but it's partially in
the driveway which was the initial call
in the first place I was not the initial
officer on scene I was not the initial
officer onene I only got requested here
because I'm a certified F officer again
I was not the initial officer on
scene I want at at the at the end of the
day I you know I could do this series
test and if she doesn't want to that's
perfectly fine but I do want to explain
everything because then it's going to go
based off of the initial officer that
was on scene's observations on how we
proceed forward that's the only thing
I'm like that I could be able to explain
cuz again I was requested to come to the
scene well she decides not to I mean she
wasn't Drive I got out of the car crying
cuz my boyfriend
cheated what is going on I just want to
leave and go to my family's house I ask
my lawyer okay that's fine so I'm just
explaining to you because I know you
she's upset and I just want to explain
to the best of my abilities if you have
questions for me I'm more than willing
to answer those questions for you to the
best of my
abilities do the test you're going to
arrest her uh it would be based off of
the initial officer's observation it
wouldn't be my my actual call I'm just
here to be a certified officer to
conduct tests if she doesn't want to
that's not my by look like that's not my
call cuz I wasn't the initial officer
I'm seen in regards to the observations
that he observed for me to even respond
to this location I was crying in the car
the car was not on your father wants to
speak with you dad I was crying in the
car the car was not
on I want I want to
call all right I'm going to call I want
to call that right
now are you going to tow the car because
it's what you wouldn't tow the car
because it's it's legally parked like I
said I'm not that's not what I came here
for I don't understand this I explain
and I expl yours are going to come pick
me up I'm I refuse any test I'm calling
my warrior this is not okay any test how
do you guys want to proceed forward from
I'm calling my
my here excuse me my father mayor here
I already spoke to your father and you
know I've been
respect officer again please go ahead
sir are you are you telling the car no
the car is legally parked right now like
I said I can go pick up the car correct
if you want to pick up the car that's
perfectly fine literally it's maybe a
maybe an inch into the driveway but like
I said I wasn't the initial officer for
this original calling I'm the certified
officer that
conducts okay I'm going to come down and
pick up the car okay do you have the
location of where the car
ISP it's going to be right across from
113 14th Street 113 14th Street in
Hoboken New Jersey let me write that
down you can also put in
1 I'm
sorry
13i Street
okay I'll see you all right who's that
the Father the father Dr Lea okay he's
on the
mayor
okay I'm sorry I know I'm sorry but this
is like I don't understand what what's
going on well you have to you have to
understand man is that I don't I'm going
to explain to you you're in you're in a
vehicle right the vehicle is on you're
in the driver's seat that is operation
of a motor be by law that's Operation my
car is not on does it doesn't even have
to be on if you're in the driver seat of
that vehicle that is Operation once you
enter the vehicle you're operating that
vehicle now you admitted that you were
drinking earlier to the officer okay so
now based off that he you know s to come
and do kcer body test for you if you I
was drinking at 12 a.m. yesterday I'm in
the medical field my family has five
generations so you haven't had a drink
today you said you drank last night yes
so why would you say you drank earlier
did I I actually drink I said I was at
City P show I said I I got into a fight
with my boyfriend you also said that
right I just wanted I said let me go
but you have to okay so this is what I'm
getting at you admitted that you were
having drinks right he was reesing a
field also Cal conduct test if you
refuse it which you can you can refuse
the test but now we have to go based off
our observations your mission to
drinking your slur speech what your
appearance your your unsteady uh
unsteadiness it's it's going to it's
it's not good for you if you if you
don't
do excuse me I no I there's cameras here
were the our body cameras are uh I know
I know my rights I'm not and I'm not and
you are within your rights to refuse but
like I said then we have to go off our
reservations so we're going to ask you
one more time are you willing to I need
to speak to my lawyer okay well I'm
going to ask you are you willing to uh
conduct the FI SP test with this officer
so yes or
no
B
well ma' I'm sorry all right I'm
answering you a question are you going
to be willing to conduct the is not
calling it I can see it from right here
all right but can you just answer my
supervisor's question please if you're
willing to conduct the F subari series
of tests that I would be able to conduct
today it's just you can say yes or no no
okay okay all right so Joe send me 1025
spring up and that's it can you please
turn around for me you you could put
your phone you could we be able to can I
please just speak to my lawyer we gave
you plenty of opportunities no you
didn't she even said you miss you got to
turn around and
put please put your phone
um on your back
right hello Mom you're arting me may you
got I don't know
please stop hurting me not hurting
you I'll just relax you
why just breathe why what am I being
arrested for I I but I
wasn't like I said you're in a vehicle
you're operating no I wasn't then you
can argue that you no I wasn't okay like
I said you could argue that in court but
you're the car you're in front driver's
seat that is Operation running no it
wasn't you have video of that
no I'm just trying to I'll
fucking we're pass that point we offer
you the opportunity and CH to do it I
have to talk to my lawyer that's fine
you can do that but you still no but I
have talk my lawyer before okay that's
fine Mark can you just grab her glasses
we have gos it was explain to you in
full detail I'm going to take okay bring
can you follow me pleas where's where's
the mom are the KE in the car man
mom was INRI no I didn't refuse no I
didn't I don't come on ma'am
I didn't refuse just let me to the
surpr that point already you got to go
inside come on man inside please stop
resisting and please slip into the
vehicle get this right you got
it this so not
right this is not
right I asked to the T I'm going to
have just hold on one second wait wait
one
[Music]
[Applause]
wait wait wa
wait
y I want to
call can you please go into the room
please yeah I want to call
my
Miss can you please stand up I have to
take uh the cffs and do another search
please you can actually face the glass
when I release one hand you're going to
put it right
on please spread your legs for me a
little bit thank
you
that right on the wall on the glass
please your hand your hand goes right on
the
Y sorry okay it's all
right same thing with this
hand are you left or right-handed
right
I have no underwear on it's we don't do
strip searches here so I'm not going to
be uh strips search you we don't do that
in in the apartment can you face me
please open your mouth Tong
up uh have a seat for me right here let
me get one sandal at a time please what
pass me your sandle one at a time you'll
get them right
back it's just part of our protocols and
procedures
[Applause]
[Music]
just one sandal at a time thank
you I nothing
ients here uh probably where do you
where do your parents recite
s r that's probably like a good 35
minute drive your dad already said that
he was going to U be on his way down
here so they'll probably be here with
next what going to happen I don't
understand what I did I'm going to
explain it to you in a second just give
me one second
please
this I'm sorry if I'm doing anything
wrong
right